حسنًا ،
هذا ليس كهرمانًا مضحكًا ، هل ترغب في
لعب لعبة تارا
أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، يجب أن أقول
تهانينا ، لقد كان
مرعبًا للغاية عندما شاهدته ، كنت
بحاجة إلى المنبه في تلك الليلة ، لذا قمت بعمل رائع يا رفاق
[ضحك]
ميليسا  سأبدأ معك
بصفتي الشخصية الرئيسية للجيل الجديد
الممثلين في الفيلم ، ما الذي حاولت
تقديمه إلى هذا الفيلم ،
وأنت تعرف أنك تحاول أن أكون صادقًا ،
وكنت محظوظًا جدًا للعمل مع جينا
وجاك الذي هو من أجل
معظم المشاهد التي تعلمتها كانت مع
هذين الممثلين الرائعين وشعرت أنني
آمن للغاية
وكل شيء كان عضويًا للغاية مع
كليهما وقد ساعد ذلك لأنه
في هذا النوع المحدد وهذه النغمة
من الفيلم  من المهم جدًا وضع
كل شيء على أرض الواقع وجعل كل شيء
صادقًا قدر الإمكان
، وهنا يأتي دور الكوميديا
ا هو المكان الذي تكون فيه مخاوف القفز هي
لأكثر رعباً ، لذلك كن
أحاول فقط أن أكون صادقًا قدر ال
مكان وأ
ا أتخلى عن أي شيء يع
بني  أفعالي حتى أنه عندما يحدث الكشف الكبير
في الفيلم يكون الأمر
صادمًا للجميع قدر الإمكان ،
أعتقد أنك سمحت ذلك
أنت تعرف جاك أحب الشخصيات التي
أحب الفيلم ، إنه أمر مرعب
حقًا ولكنه مضحك حقًا في نفس الوقت أه
فعلت  تشعر بالضغط لتكون جزءًا من هذا
الفيلم الأيقوني ، نعم بالطبع لا ،
يبدو الأمر كما لو كان حقًا امتيازًا مبدعًا ،
إنه أه
أنت تعلم أنه محبوب من قبل عشاق الرعب في
جميع أنحاء
العالم وتريد التأكد من أنه أه
تريد التأكد من إتقانه كما تعلم
تريد التأكد من أن هذا هو أيضًا
أول فيلم لم يكن wes craven على وشك توليه
، وأنت تعرف مات وتايلر
بمجرد أن أجريت مناقشة معهم ،
علمت حقًا أنهم حصلوا عليه ، لقد حصلوا
على المواد التي فهموها أه ماذا
جعل فيلم صراخ فيلمًا صاخبًا
، وكنا جميعًا في
أيدٍ قادرة جدًا ، لذا فقد خفف بالتأكيد
بعض الخوف ، لكن نعم ، لا أعرف ،
أعتقد أن الضغط قد اختفى
بمجرد أن قابلت للتو كل هؤلاء
الممثلين الرائعين الآخرين وأنا  جو  لقد تعرضت
للانفجار حقًا ، لقد فعلت
هذا حقًا رائع وميليسا أحب
الرابطة الأخوية في الفيلم ، كيف
حققتم يا رفاق ذلك ، أعني أنه كان طبيعيًا جدًا
جينا هناك يمكنك أن تأخذها
كما لو كنت تأخذ جينا لأننا
كنا كما لو كان الأمر سهلاً للغاية أخذ
هذا السؤال لا أستطيع رؤيتك لا
أعرف لماذا نعم
لا هذا
تعليق
يشبه ما كانت ميليسا
تقوله  كان الأمر سهلاً بشكل لا يصدق
وأتذكر
أنني شعرت أنه حتى عندما قرأنا الكيمياء
، كان من المثير جدًا بالنسبة لي أن أشعر
بالاتصال خاصة على شيء
مثل الشاشة ، لذلك عندما يتعلق
الأمر بتصوير الفيلم بالفعل عندما تكون
مرتاحًا جدًا مع  ممثل آخر
أشعر أنه يدفعك تقريبًا أو يتيح لك
المساحة الإبداعية للقيام بكل شيء
تشعر أنك بحاجة إلى القيام به لتقديم أفضل
أداء ممكن أو سرد
القصة بالطريقة التي تشعر أنها أكثر
أصالة بالنسبة لك حتى يكون لديك شخص ما
موهوب وفاز  متشوق وموهوب مثل
ميليسا على الجانب الآخر ، أعتقد أن أي
نوع من السندات الشقيقة أو
مشهد الأخت الذي كان لدينا يشبه
عبارة صغيرة غريبة أم
أنها كانت خاصة بشكل فظيع وأنا ممتن حقًا
لأنني أفكر في كثير من الأحيان
كممثل أنت  البحث عن تلك
المشاهد الخاصة حيث يبدو كل شيء على ما
يرام ومتصلًا ومن السهل جدًا
الشعور أنه مع ميليسا
كانت الهجمات كلها على أشخاص مرتبطين
بالقتلة الأصليين
بغض النظر عن ارتباطه بماضينا
، فقد جذبنا جميعًا إلى هنا سونيا كشرق أوسطي نحن  يسعدني جدًا أن
أرى
الممثل التونسي كجزء من هذا الامتياز المذهل والمبدع ، ما
مدى فخرك الذي تشعر به
وأنت تقول ذلك يجعلني أشعر
بفخر أكبر ،
فأنا سعيد حقًا لأن أكون جزءًا من
إنه يمثل جذوري واه
أنا متحمس لأن يشاهده الناس ،
فأنت تخاف بسهولة شديدة ما كان عليه
أن تكون جزءًا من الفيلم الذي يخيف
الناس ويخيف الآخرين ،
هل تخاف بسهولة أيضًا
أنا أشعر  أنا أحبك تحب العاهرة ،
نعم أشعر وكأنني أكثر أنا مثل
القطة الخائفة أم
نعم ، لقد
جعلتها أكثر إثارة للاهتمام ، أعتقد أنك
تعرف أن
القيام بشيء يخيفني ،
وكوني جزءًا
من ذلك كان من أجل  بالتأكيد مثير للاهتمام ، لكنني
أعتقد أن رؤية هذا النوع من التواجد في
عملية ما وراء الكواليس مثل التواجد
فيه ،
يخرج الكثير من العناصر المخيفة
منه بالتأكيد ، لكنني أبهرني عندما رأيت
الفيلم في دور العرض أم في  مثل
المسرح ، عرض الفيلم لأول مرة ،
كنت مثل القفز من مقعدي ،
لقد شاهدت هذا الفيلم من قبل
ليس هذا الفيلم.
لديك هذه الفرصة ،
كيف تشعر حيال ذلك ، نعم ، أشعر
وكأنه من الجنون أن الأمر استغرق كل هذا الوقت
الطويل ، لكن في نفس الوقت أنا سعيد
جدًا برؤية
تنوع ونوع المكان الذي
يتجه إليه حتى مع الفيلم.  أنا أتطلع حقًا إلى الأفلام التي
تمثل المزيد من الواقعية  الحياة التي تعرفها
وأمها والأشخاص في الأماكن
التي نعيش فيها ، لذا أه أنا متحمس جدًا
لذلك وأريد أن أرى المزيد من
التغيير بهذا المعنى والمزيد من التنوع
والمزيد من الفرص المقدمة
شكرًا لك  الكثير من الرجال ، هذا الفيلم حقًا
مميز جدًا للجمهور القديم في جميع
أنحاء العالم وخاصة حتى في
الشرق الأوسط ، لذلك أنا متحمس حقًا
لكل شخص لمشاهدته.
]